How closely will "Uncharted" stick to the
games?
Who's starring?
What's the story?
And most importantly, when can we watch it?
Here's everything you need to know about "Uncharted."
Cinema's influence on video games cannot be
denied.
From the mountains upon mountains of game
adaptations to the medium's fingerprint on
the direction and writing of games, movies
have a large hand in shaping games as an art form.
Some games, of course, are more movie-like
than others, and few studios are as successful
at making cinematic games as Naughty Dog.
With mega-popular titles like "The Last of
Us" and its sequel wearing their cinematic
influences on their sleeve, the company has
built its reputation as the premier cinematic
game developer in the world.
The shoe is about to be on the other foot,
however, as we get closer and closer to Sony's
film adaptation of Naughty Dog's action-adventure
series, "Uncharted."
The "Uncharted" film has had a long and troubled
production history riddled with delays but
has finally seemed to find its stride in the
past year or so.
Now, it seems reasonably certain that "Uncharted's"
most recent release date will be final.
Here is what we know so far.
Sony first went public with their plans for
an "Uncharted" movie all the way back in 2008.
Since then, there has been no end to the number
of production hurdles pushing back the film's actual release.
In the midst of more than a few rewrites,
recasts, and director pass-offs, Sony first
announced a theatrical release for 2016.
Not long afterward, the release was moved
to one date after the other, including 2017,
March 2021, July 2021, October 2021, and February
2022.
After a certain point, it seemed as if "Uncharted"
would never be released.
However, after 13 years and seven different
directors, it seems as if the movie has reached
the light at the end of the tunnel: The "Uncharted"
movie will premiere in theaters on February 18, 2022.
One of the biggest draws for the upcoming
"Uncharted" film are its two talented co-stars.
The original "Uncharted" game series focused
on the adventures of scruffy treasure hunter/thief
Nathan Drake and his suave hustling mentor,
Victor "Sully" Sullivan.
Originally, the role of Nathan Drake was supposed
to go to Mark Wahlberg.
However, after a number of rewrites, Sony
decided to focus on a younger version of the character.
They then gave the role of Nathan Drake over
to "Spider-Man: Homecoming" star Tom Holland.
However, Sony wasn't about to push Marky Mark
to the sidelines.
The benefit of telling a story about a young
Nathan Drake is that Sully is also a bit more youthful.
This opened the way for Wahlberg to step in
and assume the role of Drake's seedy father figure.
Of course, nothing is so simple when it comes
to this movie.
Fans have had mixed feelings about some of
the film's casting decisions, especially with
regard to Sully.
Holland could make a convincing younger Drake,
but Wahlberg as Sully would take some convincing.
This is especially true after rumors circulated
that this Sully might not have his iconic
mustache for the entire duration of the film.
Evidently, a stache-less Sully is akin to
heresy.
Still, many fans remain optimistic about the
film's starring duo.
"What is that thing on your face?"
"Puberty is right around the corner, kid.
You can grow your own."
The rest of the main cast includes: Antonio
Banderas, who will be playing Santiago Moncada,
the heir to a wealthy and powerful house that
once lost a fabled fortune; Sophia Ali, who
will be playing Chloe Frazier, Nathan Drake's
longtime love interest who first appeared
in "Uncharted 2"; and Tati Gabrielle, who
plays Braddock, a mercenary working against Nathan and Sully.
Sony Pictures has released an official synopsis
for the "Uncharted" movie, which reads:
"Street-smart Nathan Drake is recruited by
seasoned treasure hunter Victor 'Sully' Sullivan
to recover a fortune amassed by Ferdinand
Magellan and lost 500 years ago by the House of Moncada."
So far, so "Uncharted."
The synopsis continues,
"What starts as a heist job for the duo becomes
a globe-trotting, white-knuckle race to reach
the prize before the ruthless Santiago Moncada,
who believes he and his family are the rightful heirs."
With the villain introduced — a perfectly
cast Antonio Banderas — the synopsis concludes,
"If Nate and Sully can decipher the clues
and solve one of the world's oldest mysteries,
they stand to find $5 billion in treasure
and perhaps even Nate's long-lost brother...but
only if they can learn to work together."
Based on the plot summary, it sounds like
the movie will be very much in line with the video games.
Most games in the "Uncharted" series starts
off with Drake and Sully hunting for treasure
a circumnavigation of the planet.
Without fail, this leads Drake and Sully on
a wild goose chase rife with artifacts and
mysteries until he discovers some lost city
or vast repository of treasure.
Based on what we know about these versions
of Drake and Sully, we can determine that
the film will take place prior to the main
plotlines of any of the original "Uncharted" games.
However, the film likely won't be a straight-up
origin story, as the events regarding Drake
and Sully's initial encounter were covered
during flashback portions of "Uncharted 3."
Based on the trailers, it looks like "Uncharted"
will mine the games for action set pieces
and Easter eggs, and will likely be more of
an homage to the games than a missing chapter
in their larger story.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.